Awesome. Yeah. I love when
someone is like that. Yeah.
You know, like your friend
that hasn't talked for 22
years. I love shit like that.
You don't hear about that?
No.
Or someone that'll stop being in Van
Halen to go fuck with swords or Tom Wally
and yeah, it goes, fucks with aliens.
Do you to think they're really bringing
him to the Pentagon and shit like that?
I don't know. Cause he said
they'd like, I have no clue.
And I had watched a little bit of
your podcast where he was like, I,
you sent me a text message,
you know?
But I feel like he's made himself
readily available to do that shit.
You know? Like, I don't
know. It's a, it's,
I sit and scratch my head and go.
I don't know. I don't know either.
I just fucking, he's such a
talented, talented dude too, man.
He's like such a good song
writer. Yeah. He, well,
he certainly is certainly
a very talented guy.
It's just so interesting that
that's his main point of focus.
I would think that if aliens were real,
Trump would've told us.
I really do believe that that guy is,
he's such a fucking loose cannon.
He became the president.
Like maybe they hid it from him or his
fucking chaotic is shit is right now.
I don't know. Something would
slip. You know, I, yeah,
I would think that if they told him,
if they brought him a dose,
there's two things I would
want to know who killed JFK.
Those are two things I'd want to know if
I became the president and our aliens.
Real. What do you got motherfucker? What
do you got? I go to the top generals.
I bet it. Look, I'm going to defer to you
guys. I'm not a military expert. Okay.
And I don't want war, but, uh, I want you
guys to have support. I got full respect.
Tell me about the alien. What do
you got? What's his trunk borders,
establishment of space for? He did
that. That's right. The space for it.
But that's because there's,
that's actually a military
strategy because they're
concerned that as technology
improves,
Russians are going to be in space and
we're going to be in space or war,
fight off the aliens. Right. Like will
Smith Type Shit. Yeah. Look at him. Yeah.
Mike pence is behind them going,
Jesus is going to say almost.
Yeah. I don't know man. But if I became
president and I never will, but if I did,
those are the two things
that I'd want to know.
Who Killed Jfk and where the fucking
aliens. Do you think they know?
Do you think they know anything
more than regular people?
Because you've got to feel like
they come in every four years.
Someone would open their mouth.
Somebody knows. Somebody knows.
I don't know what MUSC
say. He's an alien. Yeah.
So he's not going to rat on his
friends. Right. If you drive that car,
I'll give you the cake.
Just take you for a tour or just take
it for a spin outta here. I will.
That fucking test will make you believe
in aliens. It doesn't even make sense.
It does not make sense.
I feel like I'm driving a computer
when I'm in a Tesla things.
It's like every car other
than that seems stupid.